balls better than the boy next door the
perfect guy so the perfect guy is
another fatal attraction ish movie just
goes down exactly how you think it would
go down this lady's datin is dude then
she's like hey we want different things
so they break up and then she meets this
other guy and he's the perfect guy he
knows everything to say it's really
charming he meets the parents they love
him and then one day he just snaps and
she's like maybe he's violent and a
little unstable so they break up and
then he starts stalking her and he acts
very violent and unstable but from the
get-go this movie was really rushed in
the course of five minutes she breaks up
with her boyfriend in the next five
minutes she establishes this
relationship with his other guy she
doesn't know like just want different
things okay and she's sitting in a bar
hürmüz drunk guy won't buy your drink
I'm really not interested she says she's
not interested walk away walk away
glad I can get you out of that pickle
hey speaking of pickle let's go in
the bathroom seriously the first time
they bang is in this sleazy ass
underground club bathroom you know like
classy ass adults I know a lot of my
friends were like yeah this is kind of
how it happens right no not when you're
a career driven adult you have things to
look forward to guys I'm letting you
know this you know beds bedrooms houses
grown up you two real like a couple
of teenagers and I know that's the point
sigh oh they're feeling young again but
that just does gross looking moving on
this movie just kind of unfolds exactly
how you think it would unfold it's like
her she likes this dude the dude becomes
nut since like I have seen this now
twice off the top of my head this year
seriously how many times can they do
this how many times can they remake
fatal attraction technically speaking
and call it something else is there you
know it's a new movie now right granted
the creepy dude in this movies kind of
being typecast as a creep now but he
does a good job of playing kind of an
unstable dick my favorite part of the
movie by far was the cop I like the
detective kind of working on her case he
was a cool guy I'd hang out with him but
in the end you're sitting there it's
like that episode of television that
you've seen over and over and over again
and you're watching it again the only
reason you'd watch this movies if you
have time to kill because you're just
doing it to pass time at this point I
mean I did it because I have YouTube
videos to do this is really like a movie
that's on TV and you're like oh hey
that's on lick and stay on but paying to
go see it in theaters not today I'll
pick my Star Wars miniatures and life
will be good lord knows why I'd be
watching this in the background while
you're painting Star Wars miniatures and
not the
fire strikes back but hey it could
happen and the time gaps were off in
this movie I feel like this entire movie
takes place in the course of about a
week and a half maybe two weeks I think
you're supposed to get the feeling that
months have passed in the course from
the beginning to the end of this movie
you don't at all the movie doesn't
succeed in that guys I'm gonna keep
this short sweet and simple because this
movie is short simple but not really
that's way the perfect guy doesn't have
bad performances in it everyone's
passable in the movie the cop was
likable if you're just accruing a
database in your head of every fatal
attraction ish movie that exists and you
want to add this to your mental
collection here you go other than that
you've seen this movie before and now
it's out here again for you to see it or
not say it use in the end the perfect
guy just left me with that feeling that
it'd probably be a good time if I was
drunk
ya know it's a Barney all right let's go
bang in the bathroom feed the drunk
is like that's the kind of guy you would
bang in the bathroom alright guys are
the perfect guy have you seen it what
did you think about it but every thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]